there's no better way to learn organic
chemistry than practicing problems so in
this lesson we're going to do some
nomenclature problems involving alkanes
and cycloalkanes I put a link in the
video description to a PDF file of the
problems that'll work in this lesson so
if you'd like to go ahead and practice
first and then follow along with me you
can do so alright let's get started okay
here's our first problem first of all we
need to identify our longest carbon
chain let's just start by counting
across this linear piece right here 1 2
3 4 5 6 7 so there's seven carbon atoms
in that chain it might look like we have
a heptane with an isopropyl group coming
off but we can't be deceived by the way
these things are drawn we need to count
in all directions so let's try also
counting up this chain to make sure we
didn't miss anything
1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8
oh well actually if we go in this
nonlinear fashion we have one extra
carbon we can also count like this 1 2 3
4 5 6 7 8 that's going to give us the
same result so this is actually in
octane let's go ahead and circle our
longest carbon chain so now if we look
at our circle we notice that these
groups are left out we want to number
our chain in such a way that these
groups the methyl groups that are
sticking off of our longest carbon chain
have the lowest number possible so we're
going to start numbering from this end
so now we can see we have a methyl group
on carbon 2 and carbon 3 so we'll have
to name this with a dimethyl prefix and
we'll need to show the numbers that we
used so we're going to write 2 comma 3
dimethyl and then use our parent chain
name which is 8 carbon so it is octane
for our next example let's try a halo
alkane okay first things first
let's look for our longest carbon chain
and don't ignore any substituents that
are sticking off try to count up those
chains as well to make sure you don't
set so here we go 1 2 3 4 5 and then if
we count across 1 2 3 4 5 6 so indeed
our longest carbon chain is this one
going linearly this time and now we have
a halogen on here and some methyl groups
so we need to think about what has
priority now halogens and methyls don't
have any priority over each other when
you're numbering them in the chain you
just want to number the chain in the
direction that hits the alkyl group or
the halide first so we're going to need
to start numbering from the left in this
case so we have hexane for our suffix
and we need to figure out how to lay out
our prefix we have a bromine and methyls
and so we want to put these in
alphabetical order and we have a
dimethyl but we're of course going to
ignore die and try in our
alphabetization of this so this compound
is going to be two bromo four four
dimethyl hexane now let's do a cyclic
example okay here we have a 1 2 3 4 5
membered ring so this is going to be a
cyclopentane now how should remember our
substituents well we have two alkyl
groups coming off so let's number we're
going to number in a way that puts the
lowest number on the substituents that
comes first in the alphabet here it's
easy it just goes in alphabetical order
so isopropyl having the I is going to be
number one and then we want to number in
a way that we hit our next substituent
with a low number so we're going to
number counterclockwise in this case so
this compound here is one isopropyl two
methyl cyclopentane now the methyl
cyclopentane is going to be all one word
I ran out of room here and I didn't want
to add a misleading dash in so just
methyl cyclopentane let's do a couple
more cyclic examples ok this is kind of
a funny example we have a cyclopropane
and we have a butyl chain so do we name
this
a butane or as a cyclopropane well the
rule is whichever one is longer will
take priority here
so butane is one two three four carbons
and cyclopropane is just three and so
it's our butane chain that we're going
to name this after we want to number in
such a way that the substituent is at
the lowest position so here we have one
cyclopropyl butane or since it's one we
can just assume that's implied and call
this cyclopropyl butane next let's look
at a ring with more than two
substituents I'm going to start counting
at the ethyl group because that'll give
me a good starting point that's
different from these so I won't lose
track so I'll just call this one for now
to figure out how many carbon atoms are
in my ring 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 ok so I have a
cyclohexane now we need to figure out
how to number this we want as many
substituents as possible as many of our
alkyl groups as possible to get low
numbers if I number this one I skip a
carbon before I can get to this one so
this would be 3 however if I start
numbering at this methyl here 1 2 3 4 my
substituents will have the lowest
numbers possible if I went in this
direction 1 2 3 4 5 so I wouldn't get
into this one until it was number 6 so
the way to do it is in this direction so
in my prefix I'll have a 1 to dimethyl
and I'll have a for ethyl but we need to
think about what order these are put in
it might be tempting to put the dimethyl
first because D is before E but remember
that's not how it's done
we actually need to think about the main
part of the prefix which is methyl and
begins with an M so actually for ethyl
is going to lead our prefix the name of
this compound will be for ethyl 1 to die
methylcyclohexane let's change it up and
do a couple problems in which we're
given the name and have to draw the
structure from it ok here we're given
trans one bromo 3 methyl
cyclohexane it's most straightforward to
just start with our suffix our
cyclohexane ring let's arbitrarily put
some numbers on this unsubstituted
cyclohexane we need to add a bromine
here at the one position and a methyl
over here at the three position but
these are trans what that means is they
are on opposite sides of the Ring and so
we need to draw one coming up and one
going back so I've added on my
substituents with a solid wedge coming
up to the bromine and a dash going back
to the methyl group to show that they're
on opposite sides of the Ring there's
actually one more possibility for this
compound I don't want to get into
stereochemistry too much in this lesson
because that's not the goal here the
goal is just naming but if we put
bromine down and the methyl coming up we
actually get a different compound these
two compounds are not the same we can't
put this on top of it and have
everything line up because the bromine
is going back in one and coming out of
the page at you in the other these are
actually mirror images of each other and
so enantiomers are possible for this
given name let's try one more problem
where we generate the structure given
the name we have three chloral five
ethyl heptane let's begin by drawing out
our seven membered chain given the
prefix heptane here is our seven carbon
chain let's add in our numbers we can
start at either end okay now we need to
add the chlorine to our three position
and our FO group to the five position
now notice these chains were each
equidistant from each end so we had a
choice if we were naming this we'd have
to figure out if we were going in this
direction or this direction of course
see for chloro comes in the alphabet
before E for ethyl and so we chose this
direction KP here if you learn something
give me a thumbs up on the way out and
for more chemistry subscribe to my
channel